i installed 1 000 mods in minecraft
i went on the internet and i just
started downloading mod after mod after
mod
after mod after my so starting now boys
track your desks whoever dies the most
in this video
has to go to walmart and buy 100 barbies
what
what what are we doing with the under
barbie or should i say what is chandler
doing so we all have zero deaths right
now
i can't hear you guys and i'm getting
hit from stuff i can't see i died
already
all right carl has one death i have a
shadow gym what's this
and we have a blanco bones compass what
does that do
no idea
okay i have slowness and soul fray i
died again good job
looks like i'm getting barbies oh no
dude this is such an
old version of minecraft half these mods
wouldn't work on new minecraft so
we had to downgrade all right i got wood
boys how what
where are you guys i died again
i died again i'm gonna have one more
rule for every diamond you find
that replaces one death that way we have
an objective oh they froze me what the
this mob just froze me are you guys
really not dying
i died i literally got one hit i just
died my fifth time
one death two
that's all right they're spawn trapping
me is what it's looking like okay
catch up dude i'm dead five times now
why do we start with only three hunger
and even weirder why is two of our
hunger blue
yeah i don't really understand when i
say i installed random mods i mean it oh
guys i found a flying zebra stop
oh my lanta wait how are you guys
surviving i've died
seven times now i got lucky and got off
oh you guys got off the island yeah
yeah i ran away what the heck i didn't
know you could just
leave the island i've died seven times
yo this pig is attacking me
oh my god the pig how many deaths is
that chandler
five but like that was the only way i
was gonna get off chandler's catching up
i'm at seven deaths i got away from the
island now now i'm not dying all the
time
is that a frog yo frogs
why is there so many demons no watch it
makes a noise
what is that i'm on the other side of
hell
jimmy come over here oh my god that tree
look at this tree chandler look at the
pyramid on top of the mountain
over there oh my god
that tree yeah you see it yeah and i'm
like
forever away let's make a tree house do
we just install a bot that just makes
giant 5 000 feet trees is that did
someone
spend time coding that yeah i was about
to say the guy was making it was like
tree
but bigger yo i was slain by a cow
yeah a pig bit me and i died i was
killed
that doesn't count oh that counts oh i'm
counting it how does a cow
what i'm back in the hole the hole of
death
i i'm getting killed by something
invisible i can't even see
it uh chandler i'm looking at a creeper
beyblade over here
i'm trapped all right well i died again
uh jimmy's a four
yeah four deaths whoa three people jim
hurry get over here oh my god what the
dealer save me
there's spring people chin they're on
begging you
i can't sprint i have no food
okay put him in the oil be gone
i'm sorry planet
[Applause]
[Music]
the zombies are shooting at me bro he's
just
busting at me ostrich ostrich
wait there's an ostrich yeah chandler
there's an ostrich
come to me on the mini-map there's an
ostrich why is there so many beams of
light from spawn
i don't know where we all died this is
our destination
all right carl i've died eight times
eight times yeah
don't go back to spawn it's horrible
what the heck is this
chandler i'm gonna kill the oh oh look
at that
it's a scorpion that poops out scorpions
who's hitting me
oh gosh i need food carl it's death
oh my god
death killed me all right now that i
have full health i'm gonna see if i get
killed by a cow again
all right oh they're all aggro all right
no no no no all right all right i'm
terri
oh i fell in a hole i fell in a hole i
fell in a hole all right let's
i'll shoot listen here cows jimmy i'm
coming
[Music]
oh my god i dude i can't even tell where
i'm going
my screen is dizzy and i'm being chased
by cows
i don't know how more terrifying it
could get i've died eight times now
officially
back up oh yeah that's right die you
stupid cow
i've died nine times now i'm stuck in
the spawn i have a feeling come on carl
you can do it minecraft girl it's not
safe out here go inside
oh oh she didn't go inside because there
was an ogre in her house
i'm coming i'm coming shrek was living
in minecraft girl's house oh my gosh
what is shrek doing here
her name is girlfriend really let's give
her name
jessica jessica thank you so much for
letting us in your home
it's scary out there we were gonna die
jessica oh there's another minecraft
girl over there there's minecraft girls
everywhere carl i'm gonna be honest i
already have a girlfriend
what the heck was that all right no well
here we need to ration our food better
we need furnaces all right we're
we're screwing up minecraft girls home
jimmy watch out oh there's a squishy
i'm terrified somebody else needs to die
because right now
i'm the one that's buying barbie dolls i
need food boys we need more hobbies
furnaces done all right screw it i'll
just go out
what the hell is that they're back
inside
no look at that three-legged thing look
at it
what is that carl i have a plan okay
okay here's my plan
yeah you run one way and i run the other
okay i don't know about this plan jimmy
go for it take it
take them all how am i supposed to fight
killer cows i'll be
being chased by a three-legged demon oh
my gosh yo what is this castle over here
yeah the pyramid that's on top of a hill
dude there's so many cows over here i
can get you guys food for days oh
get me out of the map no oh my gosh did
you go near the pyramid
no there's literally a skeleton with a
shotgun
a shotgun oh my gosh sand blocks just
popped out of
what a sand block just grew legs and
started running at me
what is that oh
my gosh i hit the minecraft girl mega
load
there's so many minecraft girls
[Laughter]
one swimming in a bikini really
my new objective kill every minecraft
girlfriend i find
what is that behemoth of a monster are
you talking about the thing running at
me yeah
i call it dog scorpion oh my gosh it is
a dog scorpion
dude it's growling at me look at the
middle of the house for a second
yeah hi hi pearl stop grabbing all the
food
oh he's catching on you need to be a
level 12 hunter
i swear we are living in hunter x hunter
so that thing could just attack us and
we don't we can't do anything about it
i'm taking on
the big oh oh good job all right come on
let's go over here let's go let's go
what are those what sheep are those
reapers look on the hill
oh my gosh taking out a bunch of reapers
yeah you guys enjoy that oh it's
darkness
oh my gosh all right i'm dead oh yo they
don't have any knock
like you can't knock them what channel
i'm coming in to save you oh
ah give me i got it got him there we go
okay what is this what is this how did
you guys survive
it's bloodlust but did you die carl yes
oh
the pigs are attacking me oh oh oh
frick i died to pigs currently i have
the least deaths so i don't have to
worry about buying barbies but
chandler at this rate you're gonna have
to buy a hundred barbers
um what's the score you have 15 deaths
carl has 11 i have six
and also we only have five minutes left
whoa that's convenient huh
sorry sorry raise your hand if you have
a diamond sword
dude this guy this guy has a tommy gun
leave me alone
oh raise your hand if you lost the
diamond swords okay
all right hey you have 11 now oh reaper
i have 12 now how many do you have
chandler oh you have 15. okay good
okay i got this in the bag i just got to
get out of the spawn okay
let's just get a whole herd of whatever
these things are this is what australia
is this is how i picture australia with
all their disgustingly scary monsters
there's andreas the child look at him
what is that
i just got excited to see oh shotgun
shotgun skeleton shotgun skeleton
shotgun skeleton hey chandler look i'm
breaking in like we did your dad's house
chandler smash that window
please die yes all right
two minutes left carl i have 13 deaths
oh come on
wait hold up there's a bad spawn why can
i not get out oh
my god jimmy is it a legitimate strat to
stay on the you died screen
nope you have to spawn in oh i died i
meant
we have one minute left carl i'm at 14
what are you at chandler 15.
oh my gosh i'm getting hit from nothing
i hate the spawn
oh my homies hate the spawn wait carl
did you die again
no not yet okay not yet but i am getting
close
28 27. oh my gosh i'm not to make it am
i going to die
probably two oh it got me to half health
no 20.
19. wait wait wait i think i might have
had diamonds hold on
16. wait a minute wait a minute 15. i
can't even run i can't even
[Music]
chandler ended with 16 deaths carl ended
with 15 and i ended with 10.
let's go buy some barbies yes
that's ridiculous i know